alors allez ce tour merci d'être là en
tout cas parce que c'est vrai que c'est
toujours courageux de venir
voilà nous voir sur ce plateau vous êtes
député la république en marge de la
drôme
vous êtes rapporteur de la loi
anti-casseurs donc vous tombez bien
alors vous bien entendu bien sûr vous
êtes pour cette loi anti casseurs est-ce
que vous pouvez revenir un petit peu sur
tous les points qui ont été abordés la
voilà et nous nous y répondit ce que
vous avez pris plein de notes et voilà
revenir pourquoi cette loi anticasseurs
pour vous et la bonne solution en tout
cas est une solution déjà merci pour
votre invitation et puis j'ai pris des
notes parce que je vous ai beaucoup
écouté je vais essayer de répondre à
tout le monde moi je déjà je voulais
prendre des nouvelles de monsieur
rodriguez mais j'espère que vous allez
vous rétablirez alors justement à l'iss
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous pensez
du k2 de jérôme praud ça c'est vraiment
un truc que j'aime ça quand vous voyez
giro mais quand vous voyez pas ce qu'il
y'a pas que jérôme il a dit voilà il ya
plein de gens il ya ya ya vingt
personnes qui ont perdu un oeil
qu'est ce qui vous vient à l'esprit
puisque il vous a pointé du doigt mine
de rien puisque vous prêt représente et
mine de rien la la la la majorité
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous avez à
lui dire déjà moi je voulais prendre de
ses nouvelles donc j'espère que vous
allez vous rétablir les images qu'on a
vues elles sont très violentes
on en a vu d'autres un des images très
violentes au cours des dernières
semaines on a appelé à notamment la
tombe du soldat inconnu qui moi m'a
beaucoup marqué la préfecture du puy en
velay avec des fonctionnaires qui ont
été enfermés dans la préfecture qui
était en feu les pompiers que qui
pouvaient pas accéder à la préfecture on
a vu quand même la porte d'un ministère
aussi sur défoncer avec benjamin
griveaux il ya quand même eu des images
très violentes et on en a vu encore vous
en avez passé tout à l'heure et même
celle que vous avez alors j'en ai fait
la régie avait voulu dépasser tout ce
soir oui parce que voilà c'est même pour
voilà pour le groupe
aussi voilà je préfère qu'on en débatte
et non mais simplement débâcle de
repasser des images voilà
mais en tout cas je pense que c'est ces
images nous ont tous choqués ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est unanime et
il faut condamner la violence quelle
qu'elle soit et je crois qu'on peut pas
opposer des souffrances j'ai entendu
tout à parler des policiers ou des
manifestants je pense que les violences
de toute façon vous l'avez rappelé à ya
mille policiers gendarmes et les
souffrances assure des deux côtés pour
les souffrances elles sont des deux
côtés et on peut pas les opposer ses
souffrances c'est la première chose je
ensuite sur le reste du débat je veux
partager mon propos a d'abord vous
répondre sur l'a7 loi que vous appelez
anti casseurs et puis on donne
la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre parce
que c'était un vrai débat aussi qui a
été qui a été abordé d'abord cette loi à
quoi elle sert l'objectif là c'est
vraiment de garantir la sécurité des
manifestants et d'une transiger ni sur
la liberté de manifester sur le droit de
s'exprimer ni sur la sécurité des
français on le voit bien aujourd'hui si
ça devient dangereux de manifester alors
on ne peut plus exprimer ses idées et ça
ça c'est un vrai problème
donc ça a été cette recherche d'
équilibre en fait tu as entre la liberté
de manifester et puis et puis aussi la
sécurité qui nous a habité pendant les
débats à l'assemblée sur tous et surtout
pour la sécurité des manifestants en
train d'écouter l'objectif est de
pouvoir manifester et de pouvoir
exprimer ses idées quand on n'est pas en
sécurité pour le faire on peut plus
exprimer 16e ça c'est quelque chose ça
c'est que n'en attendez je pense que si
je pars mais j'étais sur le web patient
faisait pas vu ce qui s'est passé vous
n'a jamais été dans une vexation
on a vu des débats qui cire confrères
qui se voit sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux
ces femmes qui sont tirées par les
cheveux ces personnes âgées qui sont
actés ni terrible des hommes il est je
pense qu'il ya des lésions la digne
salaire de chaudières comment indray
revient de vous dire je viens de vous le
dire il ya des images qui sont très
choquantes et je pense qu'on peut tous
être d'accord là dessus
évidemment je suis pas insensible je
sais pas qui vous voulez me faire passer
mais évidemment je suis choqué par ces
images comme vous et je les vois ces
images et je le vois je vois ce qui se
passe dans les manifestations
contrairement à ce que vous dites je
vais revenir sur le sur la loi parce que
vraiment la liberté de manifester il
faut le rappeler dans la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen l'a
rappelé et ses proches de la
constitution mais déjà la liberté de
s'exprimer
allait elle est soumise à au maintien de
l'ordre public dès l'article 10 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen par essence parce que je les dis
si on n'a pas de sécurité
on n'a pas la liberté de s'exprimer elle
est fondamentale cette sécurité c'est
cet équilibre qu'il faut trouver alors
qu'est ce qu'il ya dans cette loi il ya
d'abord des mesures vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure notamment une
interdiction administrative de
manifester ont dit ce qu'il a on vise
par exemple des black blocs que l'on
connaît bien qui se déplace dans toute
l'europe
leur terrain de jeu c'est pas uniquement
la france que l'on connaît notamment les
renseignements les connaisse qui n'ont
pas été condamnés en france
et ces gens là les français ne
comprennent pas que chaque semaine on
puisse les retrouver dans les
manifestations
ça c'est plus possible